I think we could all benefit from in
different ways kind of quieting our
lives for a period of time or doing a
fast from something that we consume more
than we would like but what they can do
is identify one or two substances or
behaviors that they use in an outof
control compulsive and harmful way that
they would like to manage better in
their lives and focus on giving that up
for 30 days and then seeing what the
impact is like you know life is one big
experiment why not experiment with these
everyday behaviors and habits one of the
ways to figure out how a system works is
to change a variable in that system and
and and you know record what happens and
so that's essentially what what we're
asking people do the experiment
eliminate alcohol as long as you're not
at risk for life-threatening withdrawal
right eliminate cannabis eliminate
pornography and compulsive masturbation
eliminate video games eliminate romance
novels see what happens